the trial of the former police officer
charged with killing george floyd is
expected to start next week
it has been nearly a year since floyd
died and derek shoving the officer
has pleaded not guilty to murder and
manslaughter charges
outrage over floyd's death and video of
chauvin kneeling on his neck led to what
may go down as the largest wave of
protests in american history ongoing in
many cases
the protesters have demanded greater
police accountability and an
end to systemic racism the unrest that
erupted in city after city
is reminiscent of the marches and
protests for racial equality
in the 1950s and 1960s the floyd
protests are the focus of tonight's
sixth and final episode of boiling point
the b-e-t
docu-series that looks at issues
confronting black americans through a
critical
social justice moments of the past and
now also the present
here's a clip from tonight's episode
[Music]
what we're seeing on the streets of new
york and la
and minneapolis and houston and chicago
he's not a reaction to
a public lynching though that's what
happened
we're not just seeing the reaction to
the thousand people a year roughly that
get killed by law enforcement
every year since ferguson what we're
seeing is a past
due notice for the unpaid debts owed to
black people for 400 years
today is july 4th but i don't feel like
celebrating
do you do you
for me it was really important to show
up and
not only bear witness to history but
help in
defining and shaping it today we are
reminded
of a delayed promise by this america
independence freedom and justice for all
but are we all free are we all
free when we look at
the protests that occurred during the
summer of 2020
wake up wake up and you're talking about
tens of millions of people 25 million
people 30 million people some estimates
that means these are the largest public
demonstrations in american history
like that by itself just the numbers
uh say that this is fundamentally
different
that's on b-e-t and by the way that's a
division of icon cbs
but i hope people tune in series is good
yes boiling point yes
uh you can watch that series finale of
boiling point tonight at 11
10 central again it's on b-e-t we'll be
right back